this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
and welcome to the draper fisher
Jurvetson entrepreneurial thought leader
seminar brought to you by the Stanford
Technology Ventures program and the
Business Association of Stanford
entrepreneurial students this talk is
archived for future viewing by SCPD and
the entire series of talks is generously
underwritten by DFJ I am honored and
delighted to introduce our speaker today
who is a good friend of mine and a
wonderful friend of Stanford and a
wonderful humanitarian for the world
Melinda Gates is the co-chair of the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation guided
by the belief that every life has equal
value Bill and Melinda created the
foundation to help all people lead
healthy productive lives in developing
countries the foundation focuses on
improving people's health and giving
them the chance to lift themselves out
of hunger and extreme poverty in the
United States it seeks to ensure that
all people especially those with the
fewest resources have access to the
opportunities they need to succeed in
school and in life
Melinda made headlines this July by
spearheading an initiative to reach an
additional additional 120 million women
and girls in the world's poorest
countries by 2020 thanks to new
commitments by more than 150 leaders
from donor and developing countries
international agencies civil society
foundations and the private sector she
pledged five hundred and sixty million
dollars from the Gates Foundation as
part of a campaign to expand access to
contraceptives for women in some of the
world's poorest countries with
initiatives including one to bring down
the cost of birth control and said the
foundation will devote more than 1
billion dollars to the cause between
2012 and 2022 on de was quoted as saying
that while she is involved in many of
the Foundation's endeavors empowering
women in developing world create a
better life for themselves and their
families by improving access to
contraceptives is close to her heart and
will be her life's work
Melinda received a bachelor's degree in
computer science and economics from Duke
University in 1986 and a master's in
business
administration from Dukes Fuqua School
of Business in 1987 after joining
Microsoft in 1987 she distinguished
herself in business as a leader in the
development of many of Microsoft's
multimedia products in 1996 Melinda
retired from her position as Microsoft's
general manager of information products
since then she has directed her energy
toward the nonprofit world please give a
great Stanford welcome for Melinda Gates
so um as hiset Pro first of all it's
great to be here today great to see so
many of you here I've never seen such an
attentive group three minutes before a
class starts and so I certainly wasn't
quite like that in college you know as
as heidi said and you probably know that
the mission of our foundation a belief a
deep-seated belief that bill and i share
in common is that all lives have equal
value and when we say all lives we mean
all lives because it doesn't matter
whether lived in Boston or Bangladesh or
Burundi we think that all lives have
value but we don't think that everybody
has the same chance to grow up and live
a healthy life and yet we think they
ought to have that and we think there's
something that our foundation can do
about that in partnership with a whole
host of partners around the world so
when I talk today about that foundation
I want you to know that there's not a
single thing that we do that is not in
partnership with others so when i say
we' i don't just mean the foundation I
mean with everybody that helps us carry
out this work so you know what the
mission is of the foundation all lives
have equal value and you may know a
little bit about the what and how that
plays out and I'm going to get more to
the what but I want to give you a little
bit more of a personal view about how I
think about the foundation because I'm
guessing that all of you have read a
little bit of something about my husband
and maybe even a little bit about how he
ran Microsoft or maybe a little bit
about how he thinks about the foundation
but we are very much co-chairs and
co-equals in running the foundation and
that's a really important premise for
the two of us this is our life's work
going forward and so I need to take you
back in time a little bit maybe with a
couple of stories so that you can
understand a little bit about how I
think and how we think together and then
I really want to talk about innovation
because we believe that it's true
innovation that really is going to help
lift people up all over the planet and I
to talk a little bit about why that is
and how that plays itself out so just to
take you back a little bit in time when
Bill and I were first dating which was
very briefly after I was at Microsoft in
1987 um you know we were in that getting
to know one another phase right and so
when you're getting to know one another
place you're trying a lot of new things
together and I was at the store late one
night I think I was at the drugstore
picking up some stuff and I happened to
go by the aisle where there are puzzles
and I thought hey this is something my
family's always enjoyed doing which are
puzzles maybe you know I don't really
know if Bill likes puzzles but I'll take
one home and see what he thinks
right so I pick up a 1200 piece puzzle
one of those little you know little
cheap cardboard ones you know it's
rectangular etc it was the Eiffel Tower
and with a beautiful sky behind it blue
sky very few clouds so Eiffel Tower blue
sky 1,200 pieces and I take it home and
I take it to Bill's house and my family
whenever we used to do puzzles when I
was growing up we would dump them out on
the dining room table and over a series
of a whole host of weeks and months you
know you'd come by you put five or six
pieces in and then you come by and put a
few more pieces and it may be in a
couple months go by and it's all done
well I came home and bill was he's like
yeah yeah I'll do a puzzle I love to do
puzzles so good great we crack open the
cardboard box Thursday night we throw it
open on his dining room table and one
thing I didn't quite understand about
Bill at that time was that by gosh when
you sit down to do something you are
going to finish it and you're going to
finish it then
1,200 pieces the Eiffel Tower that
that's not doable in a few hours okay
and I'm pretty good at puzzles it turns
out so is Bill we've actually have a few
puzzle competitions just for fun like
equal puzzles of same number of pieces
but um that's another story but anyway
so we done this puzzle at and we get
going and hours and hours go by and I'm
exhausted I'm like okay give it up and
we're going away for the weekend
actually do something fun with his
family and you know there's just no way
we can keep working on the singles on
the dining room table so we go away for
the weekend we come back well another
story which I won't go into but we were
had a little competition going on that
weekend to on a Northwest game called
pickleball and I dislocated my shoulder
I was with him I was on his team so we
come back at the end of weekend I'm you
know I'm hobbling like this with my I
can hardly move my hand because it's
dislocated shoulders in a sling we come
back to the puzzle and we are going to
do this puzzle and what I learned from
that as a we both like puzzles and we
like them because they're challenging
and they're interesting and there's some
similarities about what we both like
about puzzles but if we're going to do a
puzzle together we now do ones that are
600 pieces because you can do a 600
piece puzzle in one sitting and today we
do puzzles that are we don't have a
picture for that's our favorite
they're often wooden if you're doing a
picture that say of Napa Valley
completely irregular shaped edge there
might be a whole vine that goes around
it you don't know it there might be
pieces where there's straight edges in
the middle of the pieces pieces where
the puzzler has left holes in it we love
those puzzles and that's a good metaphor
for me about how we work together and
how I think about problems which is with
a puzzle you always know that there's an
end solution that the person who created
one of these jigsaw puzzles has an end
end thing in mind and you're going to
get there but along the way you're going
to experience a lot of frustration
you're going to have to look at things
from different points of view so
sometimes Bill's working on shapes and
I'm working on colors sometimes we
switch sometimes we'll notice something
the other person doesn't notice
sometimes you'll have a different
perspective sometimes you'll step away
for a while to get a different
perspective
and you'll come back a few minutes later
but you have to trust yourself when
you're doing a puzzle that you're going
to get there and you have to push
through the frustration and to me that's
part of the fun so to take you back and
this will get to the foundation because
this has a lot to do with how we think
about things at the foundation but
before I go there I want to take you
back even a little bit further in my
history which is I grew up in Dallas
Texas I'm one of four children my
parents rain-delay in French we grew up
in Dallas my dad was a mechanical
engineer he went to Georgia Tech came to
Stanford for his graduate work in
mechanical engineering my mother did not
go to college her parents didn't believe
in her going to college so they put her
in the workforce right after high school
she always wished she got in a college
degree so when I was growing up it was
deeply embedded in the for in my three
siblings and I that we were going to
college going to college and my parents
that was not going to be easy on an
engineer salary to put four children
through college and they were determined
that we could go anywhere in the country
that we could get into and that they
were going to pay for it we weren't
going to go on financial aid or
scholarships so my parents set up a
family business they we they bought and
rented out properties and then would
sell some of them as the market
increased and as a young student in high
school I mowed lawns at these rental
properties I painted I cleaned up after
people left so I learned what it was
like to work hard but my parents also
invested early in a computer they bought
one of the Apple threes that were sold
there only about 2000 of them ever sold
we owned one they still owned it if in a
closet somewhere and my sister and I
kept the books and we learned what was
then the spreadsheet approach is a calc
I learned that thing inside and out I
could program the cells I got interested
in computers and I understood the flows
of money so my parents also put us in
high school my sister and I there's a
big gap two girls and two boys they put
us in high school in Dallas Texas a
Catholic high school
all-girls Catholic High School wasn't
the best High School in the city and
that was a little bit frustrating to me
so I knew I had to work really hard at
this high school to get noticed by any
college
but along the way I met a math teacher
she was getting her PhD at night in
computer science single mom raising
three boys and she saw that I was good
in math and she said I'm going to make
sure you always know you're good at math
and she helped guide my career through
the hardest math subjects in high school
and my junior year of high school
she bought 10 computers Apple two's she
went to the head none of the school and
said I want to get these Apple two's I
want you to invest in them she convinced
this nun to invest in them and we had 10
Apple two's and what she let us girls do
was to get out ahead of her in computer
programming she taught us what she knew
and she let us run wild that then turned
into a summer job for me where I was
teaching kids both math tutoring them
and how to program and it led ultimately
to computer science degree at Duke and
ultimately to a career at Microsoft and
I tell you that because when you get
into computer science for those of you
have done it and in engineering as you
know it's a lot like a puzzle except
that there's not often a closed end
solution there might be some where
you're trying to go but there are many
possibilities to get there and you have
to have a lot of creativity and you got
to go through a lot of frustration you
got to keep your curiosity up and you
got to believe in yourself when you're
programming and I went through college
when there were very few women in
computer science after freshman year
basically none I programmed with guys
all through all through Duke and I
learned how to be good at managing teams
so when I got to Microsoft I had to make
sure that I remembered those skills when
things were tough for me at Microsoft I
loved it there I worked there for nine
years but when I would get unhappy a
little bit because I would think gosh I
have to be like somebody else I have to
manage like that person manages that
team I had to realize no I had to go
back to who I was and manage in my style
from what I'd learned in college about
forming teams and moving forward so for
me puzzles and getting into something
that's pretty
unknown is something that gives me a lot
of discomfort but is also something that
I realize you've got to work through and
at the end you can come up with
unbelievably elegant solutions if you
bring the right team together and you
guide them in the right way so now bill
and I involved in this foundation and
this very large foundation and
everything we do at the foundation it
may look to people like it's a large
foundation in terms of resources it is
the largest foundation but in terms of
the problems that we are trying to
tackle in the world we are absolutely
tiny because we are going after 27
different and distinct strategies around
problems around the world so whether
that's malaria trying to eradicate
malaria whether that's trying to find an
AIDS vaccine which is something we're
deeply involved in whether it's trying
to wipe polio off the face of the planet
and we're in the last mile of that
whether it's getting contraceptives to
women or vaccines to children or trying
to fix the u.s. education system you
want to talk about an enormous problem
we are a tiny little piece of that
puzzle but we believe that if we can
bring the right innovations and the
right things to life and get the right
partners together focused on these goals
that some of these goals we will get in
our lifetimes and we think that that can
change things for whole hopes to people
around the world so what I thought I
would do is take you through basically
two very large areas of the foundation
as I said there are 27 different areas
that we're involved in but I thought I'd
take you through two to give you an
example of innovation and also a little
bit about how we think about or I think
about the problems the first one is when
Bill and I first got in this work we got
really puzzled by this notion that so
many children were dying a year we
looked at basically deaths around the
world adult deaths and children's deaths
and to us when we read a New York Times
article and then when it got the backup
data and we
earned that children in the developing
world were dying of diarrhea we
scratched our head we said are you
kidding me
you know almost 2 million children a
year die of diarrhea when in our day and
age you go down to the drugstore and
there's a solution for it that just
shouldn't be and why is that and we
started to learn from experts and take
apart the problem and we started to
learn that millions of children were
dying from a whole series of things
children when you look at childhood
deaths you measure childhood deaths
under the age of five years and there
were two things that befuddled us really
one was why is it that this innovation
this amazing innovation of biology that
we have in the United States and we take
so for granted or in the UK or in Japan
that a vaccine that you know you've got
you grew up and got as children why does
it take 15 to 20 years for that to get
to the developing world why is that and
that shouldn't be what what is it about
the system that makes that happen and we
said as we started learn about it we
said we can do something about that that
lag should not be 15 to 20 years it
should be a year basically or less
there's just no reason and the second
thing is we started to say some of these
huge childhood deaths that are going are
because we have vaccines that don't get
out to the developing world we have
solutions but others are like rotavirus
a huge diarrheal disease we don't get it
essentially here in the United States or
you don't die of it in the United States
if you're a child let me say that you
get it but you don't die of it so there
were market failures why a vaccine there
was no rich world market for a diarrheal
vaccine or a pneumonia vaccine and again
we thought we could stimulate the
pharmaceutical companies through
public-private partnership to start to
create vaccines if we could guarantee
them a market of millions of children
getting this vaccine and then being paid
for it in the developing world but paid
just a little bit over cost but millions
of doses if we could commit to a market
and we knew that the demand would be
there we could incent them with the
right research dollars to actually
create those vaccines and that is in
fact what has happened there is now a
rotavirus vaccine on the market and
there's now a new pneumococcus vaccine I
was in Kenya over a year ago and it was
less than a year from when the new-new
macaque
vaccine came out and it was being rolled
out in Kenya with the right strains from
Kenya and what that means is that when I
was growing up in the early 1960s 20
million children died every single year
so when you look at all the children
that are born in the world 20 million
died now the majority of those deaths
happen of course in the developing world
bill and I said well that shouldn't be
but the way we track whether we're
making progress is are those childhood
deaths coming down and I'm happy to tell
you that last year there were less than
7 million childhood deaths because of
that innovation of vaccine being taken
to the developing world so that's a big
scale problem when I try to explain to
you if I tried which I won't to explain
to you you know why is it how hard is it
for Kenya to get the vaccine out to the
most remote areas what does it take in
terms of keeping a vaccine cold in
Rwanda it is incredibly complicated but
a system is set up that can work but I
want to talk to you and challenge you
about innovation and challenge your
minds to think about a slightly
different kind of innovation as well so
when I talk about these childhood deaths
under five years old 20 million back in
1960 we're now down to 7 million for
children under the age of 5 years one of
the things we didn't do as a world was
take the problem apart further until
about 2004 and in 2004 we started to
look and I say we I mean the global
community we started to look at those
childhood deaths and realize we were
only going to get the death this what
we're down to the 7 million deaths from
30 days to 5 years of life you can get a
lot of those deaths with vaccines but
guess what 40% of those 7 million deaths
happen in the first 30 days of life in a
vaccine isn't going to make a hill of
beans worth of difference for neonate
for a newborn at non-union a newborn so
what will solve the first 30 days we
have to look at what those children are
dying of in the first 30 days and that
innovation has nothing to do with
technology that innovation is something
I'm very very excited
about which is behavior change so let me
give you a concrete example there's an
amazing researcher working in northern
India where a lot of these deaths happen
he happens to be from Johns Hopkins his
name is vishwajeet
and what he has learned is that if you
teach women essentially four things to
do when their baby is born if you
understand where they're coming from
culturally and understand why they do
they have very good reasons for
believing certain things in doing what
they do if you can help them culturally
understand how to change those practices
and them to spread the practices in a
culturally acceptable way you he is
proven through great research that you
can bring down those desks by over half
just in 18 months so what is what do you
have to learn we have to learn why the
women do it in these northern remote
villages in India a lot of times the
babies are born and who's called in to
attend the birth well the
mother-in-law's there because she's part
of the power structure she's the one
that usually controls the
daughter-in-law the lowest caste member
is brought in to attend the birth
because this is considered a very dirty
event when a baby is born in their
culture because there's a lot of blood
there's a lot of placental fluid that
comes out and what happens is that
lowest caste member comes in the baby's
born
they put the baby down in the dirt and
they tend to the mother because they're
so afraid they've seen so much maternal
death they're so afraid the mother's
going to die they tend to her first and
so they put the baby aside and they let
the baby get cold by the time they come
back to the baby the baby's cold and
then the lowest caste member her job is
to scrub that baby with a gritty sandy
paste that she makes up made of usually
the soil and hand the baby back to the
mother-in-law and unless every piece of
vernix is off of that newborn baby she
hasn't done her job and she is not paid
by the mother-in-law so what we had to
teach women is that the culturally
appropriate thing to do is we ask them
when you come out of the river and
you've bathed how do you feel and they
say cool my skin feels cool what do you
do you put your sari on we say when the
baby's born
you can tend to the mother but put the
baby on the mother's chest wrap the sari
around the baby and the mother and that
kangaroo care that we've also now
learned works in the United States we've
engineered backwards that will keep the
baby's heart rate going it'll keep the
baby warm the mother's milk will start
to flow immediate an exclusive
breastfeeding is the right thing to do
so the baby doesn't get diarrhea isn't
fed dirty water which often happens
keeping the baby warm teaching them to
clean the baby with something else other
than gritty sandy paste and they were
putting an emollient on the baby a
mustard seed oil they've done it through
centuries it grows in their village and
when we were able to realize that if
they put sunflower seed they still want
to put an emollient on the baby there's
good reason for that but teach them that
something else that grows like sunflower
seed oil is actually good for the baby
if they do those four things they will
save half the baby's lives and when you
go and talk to the villagers in these
villages where they've run these pieces
of research and the villagers see the
change and you sit with a group like
this I've sat under the trees with a
group of about 200 men and women and you
say what changes have you noticed in the
village and they start talking and
talking and you'll say you'll ask them
how many of you have had have seen a
baby's death in your lifetime so many
hands go up how many of you seen a
baby's death in the last two years three
years still a lot of hands go up how
many of you have seen a baby's death in
the last year there are so few hands
because half their children that are
born or living now that social and
cultural change when you talk to the
women and you say to the Indian women
how do you spread this they say we'll
spread it and you say to them how will
you do it well they have all these
social networks like we have social
networks on the computer they have
unbelievable social networks they go
back home often to their own village to
birth they said we'll tell our sisters
we'll tell our mothers we'll try to get
the news to our mother in law's they
will spread these cultural practices if
you get the mother-in-law sold into to
part of it all the power structures
around them and if they can tell the
stories in their own way and they come
up with amazing way to tell these
stories in their own
culture that spread the news about using
sunflower seed oil or immediately
exclusively breastfeeding those
practices we know are going to be the
way to tackle this global problem of
these 40 percent of the deaths in the
first in the first 30 days of life so to
me those are innovations they're a
different kind of innovation because we
have to think very differently about
what will save children's lives and how
you create social and behavioral change
we know from centuries and centuries
about how cultures change that it's
doable but those practices have to be
spread and spread in a culturally
appropriate way so I'm going to shift
for a minute and there we have lots of
examples of innovation from the
foundation but rather than taking you
through another one I thought I would
shift for just one more section and talk
about family planning and how I got into
the work of contraceptives again when
Bill and I started the foundation and
decided we were going to get involved in
global health we were primarily
interested in two things vaccines which
I just talked about and also population
why were there why were there so many
children being born on the planet we
started down that path on both vaccines
and population and we decided to really
push forward on vaccines and then we got
involved in malaria and HIV and a whole
host of other adult issues but we've
always had this other issue on on the
back burner for some internal reasons we
didn't push forward on it but once we
felt in the last few years that we have
the right team and the more and more I
traveled I would be out for the last 15
years I've been traveling on behalf of
the foundation I go I go everywhere I go
to really really remote villages in
India remote I go to the slums in
Bangladesh I go to the slums of Nairobi
I've been to probably two dozen African
countries and I always try to sit down
and talk to the women you learned so
much talking to the men and the women
together but also the women in separate
groups will tell you a lot and I sit
down on a mat with them often me on one
side in them on another and I always try
to put myself in their shoes and I just
go in as a Western woman and a pair of
khakis and a t-shirt they don't know who
I am I'm just a Western woman who's
there
and help and when you talk to the women
and I would be trying to talk to them
about childhood vaccines and what they
know which is a lot and the distance
they'll go to get one they kept saying
to me but what about that shot what
about that shot I used to get how come
when I go to the clinic now it's not
available I have to go four times a year
every three months to get it it's a they
get a injectable shot
they said I go to great lengths I hide
it from my husband I have to take a day
off from my farm I take my new baby with
me but they say I go to the clinic I may
walk four miles and get there and it's
not there and now look how many children
I have and I was blown away by the
places I was that the women kept asking
me about this injectable because they
consider it's a shot just like we give
them childhood vaccine shots for their
children and so as I started to learn
more and learn that there are 215
million women who would like to have
access to contraceptives who don't today
and I started to think about you know
what that means for women the number of
pregnancies that happen that women don't
want to have and they will tell you they
don't want to have them they can't when
you talk to women in the developing
world and men their goal but
particularly women is to educate their
children to be able to let their
children go up healthy to be able to
feed them so they can put them in school
they're all about the next generation
but they will tell you in many many
countries if I have too many children
there's no way I can feed them so as I
started to learn more about this I kept
saying to myself but why why is this not
on the global health agenda what is it
about the history of contraceptives when
you just take the u.s. alone and you
think about the difference that
contraceptives make for women here and
when I say Condorcet contraceptives I
want to be really clear here as I said
I'm Catholic
I grew up Catholic I'm a practicing
Catholic I am NOT talking about abortion
I'm talking about contraceptives the
things we go down to the drugstore to
get or we talk to our doctors and we get
the things we use the tools in the US
but why is it but 215 million women are
telling us they want access
you them and they can't get it but that
just shouldn't be and it makes such a
huge difference in their lives so I set
out on a learning journey again kind of
like this puzzle analogy that I used at
the beginning and I was pretty
frustrated because I felt like gosh I'll
never know enough and I but I kept
thinking somebody has to speak out and I
kept looking for the person who would
speak out on this topic I kept thinking
that person will do it or this person
will do it and I realized at some point
there wasn't somebody and that that had
to be the voice of our foundation and
specifically probably need because it's
a women's issue so I went back and I
learned the history I learned what had
happened to take it off the global
health agenda what was the ugly history
of coercion in my own our own country in
mrs. sit down in Mississippi what
happened in Peru what happened in India
what happened under the LBJ
administration here what happened when
you and FPA was set up why is it that
certain religious groups are in favor
and others are not why is it that it's
so controversial in our country that we
can't even discuss it I mean we can't
even have a logical conversation not
about abortion but about contraceptives
and so I decided that this was going to
be one of the goals of my life's work
and so with divid which is the
development agency in the UK we decided
that we would put it back on the global
health agenda and we set out to raise
2.3 billion dollars to buy access
voluntary access to contraceptives for
women with the goal being to get a
hundred and twenty million new women on
contraceptives if they chose by 2020 and
I can tell you that this journey was not
easy I can tell you that the London
family planning summit where we
announced this in July in March we
didn't have the money in May we still
didn't have the money we got on stage we
were still counting the pledges leading
up to it when we got up on stage we're
able to announce that we'd raise 2.6
billion dollars for contraceptives this
is squarely back on the agenda and I
feel so strongly that we need to get
this out for women and it will change
their lives we can avert 30 million
abortions women don't want to have an
abortion but you
them in that situation if they can't
have a contraceptive we can avert three
million children dying children that
were part of unintended pregnancies we
can avert two hundred thousand women and
girls dying in childbirth every year we
would cut the maternal mortality around
the world by two fifths if we just get
contraceptives out just the
contraceptives by 2020 that I'm talking
about so we have 69 nations develop and
developing world who come together a
developing world they're putting their
national plans together they're rolling
out their own plans we're supporting
that with money and as well we're
supporting it with new research and new
technologies we're not investing in new
contraceptives but guess what there are
some exciting things that you can do in
contraceptives long term to make them
longer acting so a woman doesn't have to
go in the clinic every three months to
get a shot so that she could have
something that is much more readily
available in their village and lasts a
whole lot longer so as Heidi said that
will be my life's work and I have to
tell you it's been quite a learning
journey for me with a whole host of
experts to figure out what's even
possible in that area and I'm glad to
take more questions on that if that's of
interest so let me just say this in
closing um one very brief story which is
um when our first daughter was born Jen
when she was really young and she was
learning to tie your shoes and you know
when you're learning to tie your shoes
you probably remember you're not that
dexterous you're trying to figure it out
and it's tough and Bill and I passed by
her room and she was in there struggling
trying to learn to tie her shoes and she
was so frustrated with herself and I
kept her here and go ah ah and then we
passed by a room of humans later and she
was kind of getting the first loop done
and she said to herself this is
difficult she said but I like difficulty
and I would suggest to you that there's
not a person in this room that doesn't
like difficult you don't come to
Stanford if you don't like difficult
let's be honest here and so I'll leave
you just with a three quick thoughts
which is you're at an amazing moment in
time to be here and figure out where
your passion is and pursue it pursue it
with a vengeance
surround yourself with experts there are
so many unbelievable experts on this
campus I mean this is just it's a it's
an unbelievable place so gather experts
around you in fields you're
uncomfortable in things that you don't
know anything about and that aren't in
your major and see where you can go and
do something now because I'll tell you
it does get trickier if you decide to
have a family later to balance the work
and the end the family life there's a
time to always come back to it but do it
now I guarantee you if you believe in
innovation there are things you can do
to change the world so I'll leave you
with my favorite quote which was
something I learned early in
philanthropy from Margaret Mead and a
former anthropologist and she said never
underestimate the ability of a group of
committed individuals to change the
world in fact it's the only thing that
ever has so with that I will take
questions
either way questions sure over there yes
so I really impressed by the blog by the
Gates Foundation and spent our summer
with Peter Diamandis
like learning how housing enterprise
work for a lot of new areas of fixing a
global issue so have you ever thought of
that coming with this idea of
philanthropy 2.0 very trying to set up
the incentive prizes to drive in a way
here's all the big challenges and I'm
gonna repeat your question because
rhihub for the for anything so the
question is around incentive
competitions in order to foster further
philanthropy so one of the things um
that we've been quite involved into
something called that we set up called
the Grand Challenges and what these are
are prizes for particularly faculty
members and students who are young in
their careers who have innovative ideas
but that their idea might not get to
light without some initial funding when
we first got into setting out and these
are so we set out a series of Grand
Challenges in health these big
large-scale problems that we thought
needed to be solved and then if you said
hey I have a great idea about how to
fortify a food let's say a that a lot of
people eat in the developing world that
hasn't been done before or against this
set of Grand Challenges you could apply
for a grant and through a pretty we
tried to keep the process pretty light
you could get a first round of funding
then if we if your idea as you went
along looked promising based on the
funding we given you and you come back
again and you're able to prove that
you've gotten to a certain point we
would we would crop Preem that group
down to a smaller group and then we
would give a second round of funding and
what we've learned from that is that we
were giving to larger grants initially
what we were getting were people who
would have gotten grants anyway for
potentially from the NIH or others so
we've actually learned to make those
grants even a little bit smaller so that
the first round of funding is a smaller
amount of money we're getting so many
more ideas and we've planted this
program not just in the US now but in
China and in India and places in Africa
so what we're doing is bringing ideas
out of the lab and trying to bring them
forward against these are normal Scoble
health projects
then if you again if you make it through
the first round of funding and your idea
proves out over say 18 months then you
can come back for another round of
funding that's larger than the first one
so we do have that's just one example of
an incentive prize that we have why
don't you pick o go ahead go ahead
hmm know more about the motivations for
the foundation where does that come from
a lot of people have done computer
science like you've done coding a lot of
people from juice-off where do you go
how do you go from that to every life
has equal value of this beautiful thing
but I can't say that here so suddenly
quite yet is motivation and is the
motivation for the foundation yeah um so
I guess one other piece of little
history have to understand about both in
both bill and me is we both come from
families that believe in volunteerism
and embedded that in us very early on
Bill's parents were incredibly involved
in civic philanthropy in Seattle and his
mom sat on the low United Way board so
around the dinner table they talked a
lot about philanthropy and what was
possible and in my family we believed in
volunteerism in fact the model of the
motto of the school I went to this
all-girls Catholic school was Servian
which means to serve and so I served in
the local hospital I served in the
Dallas County Courthouse I served in the
local public school that was two miles
down the road from my school you want to
talk about a different school than mine
all you had to do was go two miles down
the road and I helped tutor in the back
of the classroom so bill and I both came
with those beliefs and literally during
the time we were engaged we decided that
the basically the vast majority of
resources from Microsoft would go back
to society it was just it's hard to
describe that that was just so natural
for us and it seemed like the right it
just seemed like the right thing to do
because we both had this belief that you
bill couldn't have done what he did
except in a country that had some of the
benefits that he had here the great
schooling the great infrastructure that
exists etc I mean as born Buffett will
often tell you you know his investment
skills wouldn't work very well on a farm
in Kenya right so we have benefited
enormous Lee from living in the United
States
so that just it was the natural press
and the question so was not if for us
then it was when and Bill always thought
it would be in his 60s that's what he
always said you know and it said his mom
would actually kind of bug him about
this when he was still early in his
career we were dating we'd go to dinner
at his parents house on Sunday night and
as mom would kind of say why don't you
be more involved in United Way he was
involved a little bit and he said Oh mom
don't bother me I'm busy with Microsoft
I'll do it when I'm 60 I'm in my 60s but
as we got going after after Jen was born
and I stopped working at Microsoft we
just we started to learn more I was
getting more time to travel and learn I
was seeing things in the field coming
home and talking about them bill would
get jazzed and read these big
development reports and get the data
behind kind of what I was seeing right
which is fantastic and we were learning
together and it just made sense to get
going and so we've gotten going in a
very small small way right after we were
married but we were getting inundated
with all these letters and things that
you feel just I mean it's heartbreaking
stuff you know a child that needs a
liver transplant in the United States
somebody dying of cancer but we started
to realize very quickly that if we
didn't focus on something we wouldn't
have impact with this money that you
could give it away in all these little
areas and they might be meaningful but
she had to have a focus you had to have
a bull's eye and then things would fall
away and it would feel okay not giving a
child here that needs a liver a liver
because you're saving a child of from
malaria in the developing world so we
just got going and it became more and
more and it became more of a learning
journey and it was actually quite
challenging when bill was working at
Microsoft he absolutely loved his job
but as you can imagine when we're going
through you know he's the CEO of the
company we're going through the doj
trial and we've got a foundation and
young kids it's challenging and where do
you find the time for you know okay
we're giving money away but we're doing
it thoughtfully and so what I would say
now which is just beautiful and neither
of us you know neither of us would have
known that this was happening is that
you know bill decided obviously to
retire from Microsoft and devote itself
himself full time and he's obviously not
60 yet and because he's enjoying it so
much and he realized I think also what a
huge difference it could make and one of
the nice things was he had always talked
to
we're dating and also in the early
married years that he really loved he's
always loved science he's always loved
innovation but he always said you know
I'd love to be around a group of broad
scientists you know I love the computer
stuff but not just in the computer field
I you know he loved biology he was
reading biology books when I was first
getting to know him on vacation and he's
always loved science and so now he gets
that aspect too he's got all these
scientists who come through the doors
the foundation and who we go out and
visit so it's honestly been kind of a
coming too for us where we had an end
goal in mind but it's more become a
learning journey and then it just it
builds on itself and next thing you know
this is what we're doing full-time so
yeah go ahead
um bills morally greatest entrepreneurs
to world's ever stayed thank spreading
entrepreneurship developed world
enabling first for successful on
tortoises scaled on and displaying fire
way too well poverty
so the question summary is is there an
opportunity build such a great
entrepreneur is there such an
opportunity to go out and spread
entrepreneurship throughout the
developing world as a way to lift people
out of poverty
there's absolutely that opportunity and
I would say if you have the passion to
do that I think that would be amazing
we don't do that only because we because
if you kind of look at if you think of
it from Maslow's hierarchy if people
can't be healthy and they don't even
have the means to feed their children
it's very hard for them to get an
education to then go on to
entrepreneurial ism and we believe in
that whole virtuous cycle that if you
can get them on the right cycle of
health which is why we do the health
stuff and then you can help them lift
themselves out of poverty get more money
off the farm to then get their kids in
school you can start that virtuous cycle
that they can lift themselves up but we
feel like you got us for us anyway
the piece we wanted attack was the
health and then the agriculture which is
the lifting themselves up to get a
little bit more means of income but yes
I think there's absolutely room form
entrepreneurialism but what we're trying
to do is deal with the bottom 2 billion
that you know to less than $2 a day
but there's absolutely that role and
that's why you're starting to see
certainly especially in the large cities
in Africa you know you're seeing more of
that I see so much ingenuity when you
have to India and lots of places in
Africa there's so much human potential
and ingenuity and we've just got to
unlock it and make it make it easier for
people you want to take someone from how
about you have any from the back so you
have some folks in the back any more
questions
way in the back there yes your
reputations of the very results-oriented
curious learner hardworking
philanthropist and I want to thank you
for that because I think it's elevated
what philanthropy can do in this world
my question is about teaching quality so
in your u.s. investment you have a new
initiative trying to uncover what a
quality teacher is and how we can
measure it and then reward and send that
kind of quality teaching I just wanted
you to talk about any of the findings
from that new initiative so glad you
asked that question hmm
the question being you've studied a lot
about teaching what makes a great
teacher and how one can spread that can
you talk about that a little bit yeah so
that's been again talked about a
learning journey for us the u.s.
education system bill and I often say
even these enormous bets we've got in
things like vaccines and malaria and HIV
are big is bad and is the u.s. education
system and probably the most difficult
thing we work on I think one of the most
encouraging things though is exactly
what you said is great teaching so I
think we all inherently know when we
have a great teacher and you inherently
when you put your kid in school you have
a sense of whether that's a great
teacher but what we knew from good
research is that a great teacher makes
an enormous difference in a student's
learning they can get a year and a
half's worth of gains you know in terms
of what the student learns from
beginning of academic year to the end
let's just talk about elementary school
in high school for a minute so I'm
talking K through 12 you can get a year
and a half gain but a bad teacher you're
not even gonna a half a year gain for a
student so you know so when you stand
back the US education system and you say
okay a third of the kids drop out before
they get to the end of high school and a
third aren't ready for college when they
get there they're going into remedial
classes in
in Community College in particular so
we're only this enormous public
education system we have
we're only educating a third of the kids
well there's something broken about the
system and so what we started to realize
is that the fix is making sure every
student has one of those great teachers
every student and as you look at the
evaluation system across the United
States ninety nine percent of teachers
98.5 I'll be exact 98.5 were being at
we're being rated satisfactory but if
that's true if 98.5 percent are
satisfactory then why aren't you know
98.5 percent of our kids ready to go on
to college it just doesn't the math
doesn't work right so we started to say
to ourselves but what makes a great
teacher so what research shows there's a
great teacher well there wasn't research
out there to show what an effective
teacher was so we kept scratching our
head saying okay we need effective
teachers we inherently think we know
what they feel like but we can't really
quantify it we don't really know what
makes a great teacher so we got several
school district 3,000 teachers to allow
us to videotape in their room we got to
see what great teaching is and the way
we knew we were getting great teaching
was they were able to take kids who were
below a certain baseline coming in an A
or at either a grade level below grade
level and get them to the next grade
level they actually when you tested the
kids at the end of the year they had
gotten your year and a half gained of
learning and so you said this is what
great teaching is and when we started to
learn what great teaching is we said how
do we sprack just practice sorry how do
we spread the practice of great teaching
and it comes down to creating a great
evaluation system like a business would
do that gives real feedback to teachers
that tells them you know these are some
master teachers let us have you go see
them and see how they're teaching these
are some things you're good at these are
some things you need to get better at
but a real evaluation system with real
rankings and ratings not just based on
kids test scores we have to put a
percentage in for kids test scores but
let peer teachers who are trained come
in and evaluate the teaching of those
teachers because now that we know what
effective teaching looks like we know
whether we're seeing it in a classroom
or not so trained peer teachers to come
in and evaluate trained principal
to really come in and evaluate not come
in once a year and do a flyby that says
is the classroom organized you know a
few other random things and that's it
and student surveys it turns out that
students do know whether it have a good
teacher it's not a popularity contest do
I like my teacher do they dress well
it's not that does your teacher help you
when you're confused does the teacher
explain concepts to the class does the
teacher go over the homework problems
with you that you miss those are about
three out of about six questions that
are super indicative of whether you
actually have an effective teacher so if
you create a real evaluation system with
peer evaluation principal evaluation
coaching and mentoring some test score
data and Student Survey data we can get
a real evaluation system that takes the
teachers who are B minuses and moves
them up to B pluses and take the B's and
move them up to A's and take the C's and
move them up to B's we have a cadre of
great teachers but we don't evaluate and
give them mentoring and coaching and
feedback and professional development
and that's what we're out to do and
we're on a journey on that through cross
the United States and it's tough uh-huh
over here um so you mentioned that one
of the problems with contraception is
not only accessibility but acceptance
and I was at a talk with an employer who
work on population growth here at
Stanford and this occupy Stanford um and
they mentioned that hammer exactly where
this was in a culture women are
completely off there was an experiment
where they started producing radio
novellas taking characters with
extremely empowered women and seeing how
that could affect how men and women
perceive themselves in that kind of a
culture so are you the Gates Foundation
doing anything to address the social
aspect with contraceptives like you did
in India with a birthing price
answer that because I can tell that
you're close enough to the mic so okay
go for it um so let me give you the most
concrete example because I think it's
super lustrated of your question which
is a great one um so I right before the
London family Sunday planning summit
this summer I went to Nisha and Senegal
and I went Tunisia air for very specific
reason
it's the highest fertility rate in the
world in terms of number of babies had
by women
it's the highest desired fertility rate
in the world in terms of how many births
men want their wives to have and the
highest desired fertility rate in the
world in terms of what women how many
children they say they want to have so I
thought okay highest of all these things
in the world super poor country is this
even possible is this even remotely
possible being contraceptives because we
know in society after society where
contraceptives have come whether you
look at France or Germany or the u.s. or
Bangladesh which has an amazing
longitudinal study since 1970 that if
you get contraceptives to women it used
to be two generations before you saw a
sea change in terms of the number of
children they have it's now one
generation and it spreads not on
socio-economic lines it spreads on
cultural lines so I thought okay me Jer
can we can we possibly get at this in
Neesha
very polygamous society so I sat down
and talked with several women in their
homes I stood by the well I was in I was
about an hour and a half outside of
neomi which is the capital out in the
desert the absolute desert and when I
was talking to women about
contraceptives I said to this one woman
she had six children and she was using
contraceptives and I said to her well
you know I was saying her about having
some in Terraria have more children she
said absolutely not and I said what are
you doing and she said I go to this
clinic and she was she was angry she
said why is it the clinic you were just
at I saw you there near my house I can
see it from my house why can't I get a
contraceptive there which I had actually
just been haranguing officials about
that too she said I have to go
essentially seven kilometres and walk in
the heat and last time I went I couldn't
get the shot she said can't you see
can't you see that we're starving here
she said we are starving starving
starving she said I can't feed my
children and and you're not getting me
this shot you're not helping me
and when I said to her well okay you
know about contraceptives and and there
actually were these village women these
health care workers who are starting to
give contraceptive pills out and they go
through the dust and they hand you a
little packet of pills not in a little
plastic case just you get the pills and
and so I said to her okay you know about
contraceptives do your sisters sisters
in the village know about it and she
said yes and she said the good thing
about women is we talk and she said we
talk by the well we talk when the
children are born and we talked when we
grind millet every day and she said and
she said so we're talking about
contraceptives and more of us are using
them and I said to her okay so there's a
polygamist Society her husband's not
there and I said so what happens if
another co wife comes in and she got
very somber and she said well I just
told you I'm not going to have any more
children but she said if another co wife
comes in I will have to have more
children because it's a race between her
and the other wife or who has the most
children to then inherit the land and
but then she stopped herself and she
said but there's nothing here
so she said and in my culture it's not
if we have to say it's not when it's if
a woman comes in but she said there's
nothing here so why would another woman
want to have a lot of children but so I
had to meet so in terms of getting
cultural change there what we have to do
is we're setting up the country not when
I say we the Global Partnership the
country is setting up husband's schools
to teach the husbands first because
they're the power structure in a
polygamous society about why having
fewer children makes sense and that it
isn't it is a decision the women think
there's no decision in this it's it's
just like if you'd gone to France many
many centuries ago women didn't know
there was a decision that they could
make about their bodies so we have to
teach the husband's first get them
involved I met with a whole group of the
mom the whole structure all the way up
in the country of the Imams and they say
yes the Koran says we can do family
planning and we need to teach that to
all the Imams in the village and we need
to get them to spread the world so
that's the way in easier to start
cultural change as the husband's and the
Imams and then get the women talking and
get the contraceptives in and let them
make the decision then
yes for the initiative so I yeah when
you talk about contraceptive it's more
like it appears or injectable so because
I read some reports they in the
association or correlation between from
baby increased breast cancer or some you
know some side effects from
contraceptives so you mentioned the
father school or that does all sound
because I think one initiative maybe
we'll start on the man you know could
you when I know definitely cannot do
this and also maybe some women can ever
effective or their body movements that
was amazing so do you have like
complementary programs in your
initiatives to basically address the
part of population yes so so one of the
myths and contraceptives one of the the
things that was wrong with the system is
if you ask yourself are there
contraceptive stock-outs in the
developing world country after country
would tell you know we're stock we have
stocks you know eighty ninety percent of
the time we had to dig deeper to find
out that actually what they had in stock
were condoms there are lots of condoms
because of hiv/aids and everything that
PEPFAR the President's Emergency Plan
for AIDS relief has done in these
countries there are lots of condoms but
women will tell you over and over again
they have no power to negotiate a condom
in their relationship because they said
if I say especially African women will
tell you they say if I say to my husband
I want him to wear a condom I'm either
accusing him of having AIDS or I must
have been not been I've been outside my
relationship I'm saying I'm worried that
I have AIDS so she doesn't have that
power so we need to give her options
that she can decide you need to give
make sure she's got pills she's got the
injectable but a longer-lasting
injectable eventually one she could give
herself we're working on one that's a
little blister pack an implant implants
are very popular in place in many places
in the world where you put a few rods in
your arm and the implants last five
years we're bringing the prices of those
down long term there's even talk you
want to talk about innovation of a
microchip that could be put under a
woman's arm here in the US
and actually in Britain there's a
microchip that's being developed to
deliver an osteoporosis drug if that
comes to fruition you could probably
also load a contraceptive into it so and
we have to look at I mean in believing
we are part of studying the side effects
of hormonal contraceptives making sure
they're safe for women making sure
countries follow their own policies but
there's a whole range of options if we
invest in the right way so one last
question somewhere in the back yes I
know you're looking for understanding
evolution what is your message for
people who potentially can't help you
great question great way to close your
your message to other people what would
your message be for how they can help
you and you've got a good audience of
very capable people here to know that
well I would say first get get involved
but start to learn learn about something
you're passionate about and pick your
area in philanthropy doesn't have to be
one of ours it might be one of ours and
then one of the fantastic things as you
all know even better than I do about
social media these days is you can
connect via the web and connect in very
meaningful ways so I would say this if
you have the opportunity to go to the
developing world your eyes will be open
I will I would just least say in a way
that probably you'll never be able to
turn away that's how I felt that's what
got me started our first trip to Africa
which was a vacation I couldn't turn
away after that I went to see the
animals I loved it but it was the people
you can't turn your back so I would say
get involved if you can go to the
developing world do if you can volunteer
in a school here volunteer in a hospital
start to learn what the problems are but
then connect via the web DonorsChoose is
a fantastic website if you want to give
$30 to a classroom you know a few
dollars to help a teacher buy a printer
she needs for a classroom that's in you
know a bad part of of Oakland where she
can't get a LaserJet helped her do that
if you want to go up on catapult and
learn about projects in the developing
world microloans for womens
contributing to helping buy
contraceptives for women or buy a
vaccine for somebody all of those
options exist on the web and are very
well researched and in place we're
involved in a whole host of them one of
them is catapult we fund donors
there are lots of places you can go on
the web if you want to donate money but
there's also donating your time and
donating your energy and I would
encourage you to do that too and do that
locally there's so many things to get
involved in well I want to thank you
very much
you